one of the things that i love most about
being here is i have a ton of friends
here and i have a ton of creative
friends who like to come around and [__]
around with me and do weird [__] i have
another one of my friends in back
uh ladies and gentlemen from nsync mr
chris kirkpatrick everybody
[Applause]
oh yeah are we out here come on up man
come on up there he is
kris kirkpatrick everybody
[Applause]
you're the only person here that
i don't understand how we're friends
like i sat here all night going i can go
out the back and no one will ever know i
was ever here just tell josh don't call
me up because this is getting ridiculous
tonight
hey guys i'm gonna do is set about weed
let me bring my instinct buddy uh
hey come on up did you did you see him
put dre's titty in his mouth
i don't think you saw it i i
i saw the whole thing and i i just
looked i was like i was going to send
some sympathy cards to dre yeah because
i know dre was trying to be funny and
yeah i don't know what's going on right
here but y'all are out of control
starting with your shirt
are there sea horses on your shirt
those are geckos come here and see them
all right
well listen guys blend in um
[Music]
so are you ready to sing this song no
hey seriously seriously i've like
phillip you know
tonight is like i don't know what you're
on tonight but like
you're actually singing pretty good like
i wouldn't kick you off some of the
talent shows hey hey which is a post in
most times where i'm usually like that's
my friend good thing he's [__] funny
guess what's your job guess what that's
because i didn't take 100 milligram
edibles just 25.
[Applause]
oh cool more weed jokes
no i'm a responsible adult um okay
so uh you ready
all right let's see what you got
sounds like one of our songs it might be
oh and by the way i changed a couple
lyrics
that's okay so did i oh [__]
it was the first date that
my mom set up
it was uncomfortable
oh
i remember she told me
in her past life that she was a cat
and not only that she had three extra
toes
she let her back hair grow
she was raising five little kids
from five different dicks i really want
to leave
but mom will be mad at me
so guess what
i'm gonna need weed
[Applause]
it's early in the morning
in a long line you know to get your
coffee
one person in front of you
she seems really confused what's in a
chai
are those muffins dry hey lady what the
[__]
have you never been to starbucks
there's a lot of an angry
mob
going to shank list jobs and i forgot
the words
because i changed them up
so guess what
i don't need any more weeds
[Applause]
[Music]
there comes a day
when you have to go to your cousin's
wedding
and you're gonna
[Music]
you don't like your ass so you take a
bar class whatever your reason be
it's just enough for me guess what we're
gonna need weight
hey
please don't tell any of the other guys
that i just did that are you kidding me
i'm live streaming with fatone right now
[Applause]
oh [__]
no the really weird part was i thought
we were doing this like three weeks ago
when you said we were yeah yeah so i had
the words memorized and over and over in
my head then they go hey we need you to
do this anti-drug thing in vegas can you
come out and sing it's going to be me
nope
chris kirkpatrick
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
is
[Music]
foreign